there are three levels of black lives
matter demands okay
black don't forget black lives matter is
an organization it has a website it has
a list of demands it has a who we are
page you go to black lives matter calm I
think it is calm org one of the two you
can go to the website here's what you
expect them to say they say ok they want
to expose and prevent police brutality
they want to stop unjust deaths at the
hands of vigilantes they want to stop
the general racism the threatens black
lives ok right yeah totally we all get
that we all agree with them there's a
little bit less what you expect but
still within the realm of understanding
their black identity runs in the same
way that you have white identitarian x'
they are black identitarian they say
we're unapologetically black capital B
in our positioning and the capital B
matters here right they're not just
saying we're one group of Americans
they're saying we're black this is a
separate thing in affirming the black
lives matter we need not qualify our
position to love and desire freedom and
justice for ourselves is a prerequisite
for wanting the same for others here's
the money line we see ourselves as part
of the global black community and we're
aware of the different ways we're
impacted or privileged as black people
who exist in different parts of the
world
so already you hear a little bit of this
more Marxist language all around the
world
transnational not not focusing on bonds
of national loyalty not saying we're
Americans we love America no they're
saying we're part of the global black
community black people of the world
unite
getting a little bit more of an explicit
Marxist message but still within the
realm ok it's called black lives matter
obviously it's gonna have a little bit
of a black identitarian component to it
then you get to the craziest level this
is from the black lives matter website
we are self reflexive and do the work
required to dismantle cisgender
privilege and uplift black trans folk
huh
what so look don't don't mistake this
they're not intersectional in the way
that leftist politics usually is saying
like yeah you know the Hispanics have
something in common with the Muslims
have something in common with the
lesbian tap dancers have something in
common we right with all the disparate
oppression groups that then can go and
attack the oppressor group of straight
white men who think that they're men
come from money who could write on and
on and on that's not what's happening
every qualification here transwomen it's
all about being black which is in a way
a little bit refreshing and leftist
politics because it's a little more
old-school it's a little more old-school
Marxism than whatever has been happening
for the last few decades they say
especially we want to protect black
trans women who continue to be
disproportionately impacted by trans
antagonistic violence all this language
cisgender privilege trans folk is the
language of radicals we build a space
that affirms black women and is free
from sexism misogyny and environments in
which men are centered okay getting more
into the sexual politics we practice
empathy we engage comrades comrades -
the intent with the intent to learn
about and connect with their contexts
comrades an explicitly communist term we
make our spaces family-friendly and
enable parents to fully participate with
their children we dismantle the
patriarchal practice that requires
mothers to work double shifts okay so
now the patriarchy is involved here and
then this is the money line we disrupt
the Western proscribed nuclear family
structure requirement by supporting each
other as extended families and villages
that collectively care for one another
especially for our children to the
degree that mothers parents and children
are comfortable if you support the
nuclear family then you are standing in
opposition to black lives matter the
Western proscribed nuclear family as
they put it and then we foster a queer
affirming Network when we gather we do
so with the intention of free ourselves
from the tight grip of heteronormative
thinking or rather the belief that all
in the world are heterosexual unless she
he they disclose otherwise right so the
same kind of sexual revolutionary
language it is not possible to be a
conservative and to support the black
lives matter movement it is not possible
to be a reasonable person and support
the black lives matter movement a lot of
conservatives even conservatives a lot
of reasonable people think they support
the black lives matter movement
they think that black lives matter and
they think the black lives matter
movement is about how black lives matter
that's not what it's about okay I think
the best analogy would be what they do
in Congress you know I'm looking down
the street I can see the Capitol down
the street this is what they do in
Congress whenever there's a really bad
bill really ugly awful legislation that
is really harmful to people they give it
a really nice sounding name so you can
almost judge how bad a bill is by how
nice the name sounds they will cram in
the worst policies ever and then they'll
call the bill the don't murder puppies
Act of 2020 they'll say okay congressmen
are you gonna vote for the don't murder
puppies Act of 2020 and then you're in a
bad spot because you say actually that
bill is really terrible and it includes
all this stuff that everyone's gonna
hate it's going to destroy all of our
lives but they'll say but it's called
the don't murder puppies act so you got
a support it's the same thing with black
lives matter let's say you hold it you
don't support black lives matter what
are you a racist what are you a bigot
what are you a white supremacist
neo-nazi Klansmen Nazi supremacists
you say no I just you know I don't think
we should destroy the family so I can't
they tell me that if I support the
family I can't support BLM and that's
true that's exactly what's going on here
and I get it there are a lot of people
who posted the stupid square on social
media because basically everybody
pressured them into doing it and you
don't want to lose your job if you
didn't do it you thought it meant that
you support black people so now what it
means do not support black lives matter
no one should support this terrible
terrible radical leftist disastrous
awful how many more bad adjectives can I
use organization it's not possible to
support your country to support your
family to support any sort of reasonable
politics and support this radical
movement and they should be shunned from
the mainstream of radical politics
before they do even more damage
like for instance destroy the cops
[Music]